I was on the reddit discussion forum
this morning and found some really
interesting discussions and threads that
I want to tell you about all of these
are public and you can participate that
participated in them whenever you want
starting with a discussion about the
term cultural reactionary this is very
interesting and it points out that
there's a movement that is not so much
aligned with the left or right from a
policy standpoint but that it is a
culturally reactionary
sort of mentality and I don't have to
name some of the people that there's
redditor names but you can check out
this discussion thread and participate
if you want I think that this is a very
interesting concept the growing cultural
reactionary movement sometimes called
libertarian sometimes called alt-right
sometimes called classical liberal
there's a whole bunch of different
phrases used for what is increasingly a
culturally reactionary movement that is
very very interesting also on our reddit
discussion forum trivia Barack Obama's
very long run-on sentence this is funny
I recently discussed on a YouTube
livestream how President Obama had this
ability for sort of nested multi-tiered
speech where he could go and branch out
when answering a question and then bring
it all back and answer the original
question but I never said that if you
charted it out and actually put it on
paper it would be grammatically correct
and this is a really really funny on
analysis of what is effectively a very
long run-on sentence from President
Obama but because he's such a good
orator President Obama could make a
run-on sentence
seem like a delicately constructed prose
whereas Donald Trump can take a
grammatical speech and make it sound
like the ramblings of someone who can
barely speak English so very very
different oratory skills from our
current and former president also on our
reddit discussion forum about growing
trees and carbon there has been a sort
of back and forth about whether young
trees or old trees sequester more carbon
from the atmosphere and
after having multiple voicemails from
callers about that there is now an
attempt to answer the question
scientifically at david pakman.com slash
reddit which is interesting ultimately I
don't know that my life will be changed
because I'm not going to be chopping
down many trees in my life so it's not a
decision I'm going to have to make but
interesting nonetheless and lastly on
our reddit discussion forum I will now
create the final exam for david pakman
Scala CH class this is very funny I'm
teaching a class at Boston College in
the communication department this
semester and someone jokingly suggested
that the final exam should be watching
my interview with Jessie Lee Peterson
which was a total gongshow BS a BS show
of an interview and identifying every
logical fallacy that would probably
require a hundred pages that it's too
much work for a final exam in an
undergraduate college course participate
on reddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t approaching 4500 and eventually 5,000
of our viewers and listeners on reddit